[Musique]
chers amis merci infiniment et merci
d'abord à vous tous d'être présent ce
soir merci d'être si nombreux j'arrive
comme laurent de paris j'étais encore à
midi sur les plateaux de télévision
et bien je peux vous dire une chose
c'est que sur les plateaux de télévision
à paris il ya une seule certitude c'est
que vous n'existez pas cette élection
elle est plié elle est finie rentrez
chez vous qu'est ce que vous faites là
de toute façon le débat il est déjà
installé et on ne cesse de nous demander
par tous de nous placer dans un camp
comme si tout était déjà joué comme si
c'était tu l'as dit guillaume le
troisième tour de l'élection
présidentielle une sorte d'éternel
retour cauchemardesque vers ce débat
d'entre deux tour entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron et bien moi je dis que
rien n'est joué d'avancé et la meilleure
preuve de cela c'est votre présence ce
soir ici à bordeaux merci la trifi ce
soir
je voudrais remercier de tout coeur tous
les élus qui sont ici remercier nos
parlementaires nos sénateurs qui sont là
nombreux remercier didier quentin le
député qui a survécu à la tempête de
2017 remercier tous nos mères qui
représente ce par quoi à la france tient
encore debout nos conseillers municipaux
conseillers départementaux conseillers
régionaux dans un moment de crise
profonde je le vois depuis le début de
cette campagne partout en france ils
sont ce par quoi notre démocratie
résiste à la défiance qui ne cesse de
monter
tous ces élus de terrain qui dans la
discrétion et le silence retisse le
tissu social abîmé réparé ce qui est
déchiré rapproche ce qui s'est éloigné
et je crois que nous devons leur dire ce
soir notre reconnaissance pour tout le
travail qu'ils font ils sont la force de
notre famille politique et sont la force
de la france
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier aussi tous ceux
qui portent avec nous cette campagne
remercier en particulier bien sûr nos
amis centristes hervé morin et puis
remercié puisque ce soir c'est chez toi
que nous sommes je voudrais dire de tout
coeur un immense merci à eddie puyjalon
tu l'as dit nous défendons ensemble
cette france que nous aimons nous
défendons cette france qui n'a pas
renoncé à elle-même qui n'a pas renoncé
à ses coutumes qui n'a pas renoncé à ce
bon mot de tradition qui fait le dernier
mot de cpnt la tradition qui vient du
latin tradé ray qui veut dire simplement
ce qui se transmet la france n'est pas
née d'aujourd'hui la france n'est pas un
nouveau monde
la france sait faire des start up mais
la france n'est pas une start up nation
et ce qui fait notre inventivité c'est
que nous n'avons pas commencé avec ce
monde qui se dessine
nous puisons notre génie dans cette
histoire qui remonte il y a bien loin de
ceux là dans cette histoire qui fait
cette filiation que tu évoquais à
l'instant et oui nous nous honorons oui
c'est notre fierté
et oui c'est notre meneur de pouvoir
entretenir la flamme la tradition disait
gustav mahler ça n'est pas vénérer
descendre mais c'est ce passé le feu
voilà ce que nous faisons ensemble merci
clé réduit
et puis je voudrais bien sûr remercié je
les fait de nombreuses fois mais il faut
le faire encore avec vous ce soir je
voudrais remercier celui par qui nous
sommes là ensemble réunit remercier
celui qui a fait ce choix totalement
improbable qui me vaut d'être devant
vous celui qui m'a fait confiance et
j'espère que je serai à la hauteur de
son pari à la hauteur de sa confiance je
voudrais remercier laurent laurent tu
m'as fait un un double cadeau d'abord
parce que c'est un honneur immense que
d'être devant vous je sais que je ne
mérite pas les mots que vous avez
prononcé chez rives toi qui nous
accueille
tu as confiance me touche profondément
je sais que je ne vais pas encore
méritait et qu'il va falloir maintenant
dans les semaines qui viendront dans les
années qui viendront que je puisse faire
en sorte que cette confiance soient
fondés sur ce que nous pouvons faire
ensemble pour ce territoire pour cette
ville pour cette région pour cette
fédération que tu présides pour toute
notre france que nous voulons servir
ensemble mais au fond cette confiance
que tu m'as fait laurent ça n'était pas
le seul cadeau le grand cadeau que tu
m'as fait c'est de me permettre de
partir entouré d'une équipe aussi
extraordinaire avec agnès avec arnaud
avec tous nos policiers et vous les avez
vu ce soir ils sont nombreux comme
jamais dans cette région ici ce soir et
je voudrais leur dire de tout coeur un
immense merci merci romain toi qui a été
presque de tous les meetings
merci didier tout avec qui nous avons
échangé avant même que tu sois sur cette
liste nous viendrons bien sûr dans ta
commune tous ensemble d'accords on se
donne rendez vous ensemble
merci chers hortense toi qui est aussi
une figure de notre génération sur cette
liste merci sylvie merci patrick nous
nous sommes croisés ensemble déjà dans
d'autres rencontres
et puis merci david au fond c'est une
chance d'arriver à cette fin de campagne
déjà à la fin de campagne que de chemin
parcouru
déjà à la fin de campagne et je vois une
grande différence avec les premières
réunions
c'est que maintenant quand je rentre
dans une salle je croise tant de visages
amis chers david nous avons été chez toi
en charente en charente maritime avec
d'autres qui sont ici et nous avons
partagé déjà ce qui fait la saveur
singulière de cette région où nous
sommes et puis merci bien sûr guillaume
toi qui viens de parler
guillaume toi que quand j'ai rencontré
on m'a présenté comme le plus efficace
de tous les tombeurs de notre parti
politique
le tombeur de limoges toi qui porte les
victoire improbable toi qui fais les
succès dans le plus grand des défis
c'est une chance incroyable que vous
soyez la force de cette liste
aujourd'hui alors au risque de te
décevoir
guillaume je ne vais pas faire la
surprise non parce que de fait je ne
peux pas faire la surprise
nous allons faire la surprise et nous
allons la faire ensemble
et nous devons la faire ensemble cette
surprise nous devons la faire ensemble
parce que c'est notre europe qui a
besoin de cette surprise c'est notre
france qui a besoin de cette surprise si
nous voulons refonder l'europe pour
pouvoir rétablir la france alors oui
nous n'avons pas le droit de manquer la
semaine qui commence car tout se joue
dans cette semaine nous sommes ici avec
le bonheur de nous retrouver ensemble
mais nous sommes aussi ici avec au coeur
une forme de gravité peut être une
inquiétude partagée
nous sommes au coeur d'une période
marquée par une crise profonde
certes ans nous faisons partie d'une
génération avec tous les jeunes qui sont
ici ils sont nombreux ce soir d'ailleurs
et c'est une joie particulière
nous faisons partie d'une génération qui
année qui a découvert le monde qui a vu
naître sa conscience du monde dans
lequel nous sommes
avec ce mot de crise est partout
aujourd'hui partout notre regard se pose
nous voyons de la crise crise économique
qui dure depuis si longtemps crise
sociale bien sûr née de cette crise
économique chômage de masse qui traverse
notre pays d'une manière maintenant
structurelles crise avec cette défiance
qui monte des institutions crise de
l'autorité crise de l'état crise de
l'état qui stats devrait demeurer
toujours et qui n'est plus fait que de
ses dettes qui semble devoir se passer
aux générations qui viennent crise
culturelle crise éducative crise de la
transmission
mais à travers même la crise de la
culture et au delà d'elle crise de la
nature crise écologique qui fait que
nous avons le sentiment que même notre
environnement semble menacée par cette
instabilité fondamentale nous vivons une
période de crise globale et ce constat
n'a pas pour but de nous rendre
inutilement des primes et non la crise
n'est pas forcément une catastrophe
notre pays a connu des moments bien plus
tragique que celui que nous vivons
aujourd'hui
mais notre pays a sans doute rarement
connu des moments aussi critique
c'est à dire des moments où krisis comme
le dit le mot grec qui a fait à travers
cette langue notre vocabulaire
d'aujourd'hui krisis
le moment de la décision krisis en grec
veut dire le choix
nous sommes à l'heure des choix nous
sommes au moment où il faut chercher ce
nouveau cap dont nous avons besoin
prendre les décisions nécessaires pour
pouvoir faire en sorte de redessiner un
avenir de re découvrir qu'il y a
effectivement un espoir est que nous ne
sommes pas condamnés à cette fatalité
qui veut que nous soyons aujourd'hui en
train de subir un monde qui avance sans
nous au lieu de contribuer à agir pour
en infléchir la direction oui nous
sommes à l'heure des grandes décisions
et dans cette heure des grandes
décisions
il nous faut pouvoir nous appuyer sur
une europe fondée pour pouvoir être
efficace face à tous ces grands défis
face aux défis économiques et
commerciales aujourd'hui nous avons le
sentiment c'est vrai que les grandes
puissances du monde sont en dehors de
l'europe que l'avenir technologique que
l'avenir économique industrielle que
l'avenir agricole peut-être est en train
de se jouer ailleurs aux états unis en
chine en inde en amérique du sud
et pourtant nous n'avons aucune raison
de nous résigner mais il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons le sentiment
de céder à une forme d'impuissance de
reculer de perdre du terrain de perdre
des marchés
pourquoi sinon parce que notre europe a
cédé à cette naïveté
nous avons vécu longtemps et longtemps
nous avons construit cette europe dans
le rêve de la fin de l'histoire
la fin de l'histoire si vous vous en
souvenez ce concept inventé par un
philosophe américain qui s'appelait
francis fukuyama dans les années 90
francis fukuyama avait écrit ce livre la
fin de l'histoire dans lequel il pose
est le constat suivant le mur de berlin
s'est effondré et personne ne s'étant
fut à l'est
mais certains ont mis du temps à s'en
rendre compte le mur de berlin s'est
effondré et personne ne s'est enfui à
l'est et donc l'histoire a tranché
l'empiré soviétique s'est écroulé et
personne ne le regrettez donc c'est le
triomphe d'un seul modèle le modèle de
la démocratie libérale le modèle de
l'économie de marché et avec le triomphe
de ce modèle destiné à devenir universel
le monde va désormais vivre la fin de
l'histoire humaine la fin de toutes les
péripéties qui ont fait l'histoire
humaine
oh bien sûr disait fukuyama il y aura
encore des gazettes dans laquelle on
racontera les résultats des matchs de
foot mais il y aura plus de grands
événements plus de guerre plus de
conflits désormais toutes les barrières
vont s'abaisser toutes les frontières
vont se défaire les identités se diluer
et de l'époque où le citoyen politiques
préoccupés de l'avenir de son pays
s'inquiétait pour son avenir nous allons
passer à l'époque dans laquelle le
consommateur satisfaits se verra offrir
le meilleur produit au moindre coût par
une concurrence universel
c'était le rêve de la fin de l'histoire
c'était comme le disait fukuyama dans un
syntagme délicieusement vintage c'était
la victoire du magnétoscope et ben de
fait ça ne s'est pas tout à fait assez
comme ça ça ne s'est pas tout à fait
passé comme ça et nous vivons
aujourd'hui la fin de la fin de
l'histoire
nous vivons aujourd'hui ce que vous
voyez tous les jours dans vos journaux
sur vos chaînes de télévision la montée
de ces tensions économiques et
commerciales qui nous prouvent
quotidiennement que non les intérêts
particuliers ne se sont pas remis et que
non les frontières ne se sont pas
abaissés et que oui évidemment la
politique existe encore
les américains ont une politique
économique et commerciale extrêmement
affirmé pour défendre leurs intérêts les
chinois ont une politique industrielle
extrêmement extrêmement agressive est
forte et nous en europe nous eh bien
nous n'avons encore qu'une doctrine de
la concurrence vous l'avez vu avec le
dossier alsthom si mince on pourrait
revenir longtemps sur ce rapprochement
entre ces deux grandes entreprises
industrielles il y aurait tellement en
dira sans doute ce dossier n'était-il
pas bien ajustée sans doute fallait-il
le reprendre
le rééquilibrer il n'en reste pas moins
que tout le monde s'est rendu compte à
l'occasion de l'échec de la fusion entre
ses deux grandes entreprises
industrielles européennes que nous
étions en train de nous tirer des balles
dans le pied
nos entreprises doivent faire face à des
géants issus de ces grandes puissances
qui sont en situation de monopole sur
leur territoire de départ et qui sont
largement soutenues par des aides d'état
respectifs et nous face à ces géants
nous interdisons à nos propres
entreprises de se conforter les unes par
les autres de se rapprocher les unes des
autres et de faire en sorte qu'elle
devienne plus forte dans la compétition
mondiale
oui nous devons retrouver une vraie
stratégie industrielle et commerciale
oui nous devons assumer enfin que
l'europe doit d'abord défendre nos
entreprises et nos emplois
et oui nous devons assumer que l'europe
nous devons assumer que l'europe ne doit
pas être le seul endroit au monde où
l'on croit que le principal dans le
commerce et l'économie c'est de renoncer
à défendre ses propres intérêts nous ne
voulons pas nous replier entre quatre
murs nous sommes ici dans ce territoire
magnifique qui a vu la france rayonner
dans le monde entier
nous sommes ici au coeur d'un peuple
industrie d'un peuple de commerçante
d'un peuple qui a conquis le monde par
l'excellence des savoir-faire qu'il a su
vendre partout sur tous les continents
du monde
nous n'avons pas pour but de construire
quatre murs entre lesquels mourir à
petit feu en nous mettant à l'écart de
ce monde qui avance récents nous nous
croyons à la force de nos entreprises
nous croyons à l'excellence de ses
savoir-faire qui peuvent encore marqué
tous les pays autour de nous nous
croyons cher guillaume au génie de ces
agriculteurs qui se sont transmis de
génération en génération des
savoir-faire magnifique qui
entretiennent des terroirs
exceptionnelle et qui ont su non
seulement transmettre cet héritage mais
l'actualiser le réinventer le moderniser
qui ont su se projeter dans l'avenir
non nous ne croyons pas contrairement à
ce que dit le ministre de l'agriculture
que l'avenir de l'agriculture ce soit de
retrouver les techniques de nos grands
parents
nous savons que le génie nos
agriculteurs peut marquer l'actualité et
le futur du monde dans lequel nous
sommes et nous croyons d'ailleurs disons
le en passant que c'est aussi notre
responsabilité à nous la france nous
sommes ici dans cette terre ou
montesquieu a inventé la théorie des
climats et oui les climats existe bien
et nous avons en france ce climat
incroyablement tempéré favorable ce
climat modéré que vous connaissez bien
dans cette région et qui permet à la
france de voir grandir et de voir
pousser les plus belles races d'élevage
les plus belles plantes à cultiver et
nous avons le devoir bien sûr de
continuer à soutenir cette agriculture
française qui n'est pas une agriculture
médiocre et pauvres qui au contraire est
l'une des dernières activités
économiques de notre pays qui soit
excédentaire commercialement une
agriculture qui exporte une agriculture
qui rayonne nous avons été nous avons
été un peu les seuls dans cette campagne
à défendre cette agriculture
à notre droite comme à notre gauche on
ne parle que de circuits courts de
petites quantités avec de grandes
qualités on ne parle que de bio bien sûr
tout cela est très important et bien sûr
il faut que nous puissions encourager
les circuits courts pour pouvoir faire
en sorte que dans nos cantines dans nos
écoles nos enfants puissent se nourrir
des produits cultivés localement mais
allez donc à cognac aller parler à
cognac de circuits courts aller parler à
cognac d'une agriculture qui se
contenterait de nourrir les alentours
aller parler à cognac aller parler à des
viticulteurs bordelais allaient parler
de ce que c'est qu'une agriculture
française qui renonceraient à exporter
et vous allez voir comment ils entendent
le discours que vous tenez sur cette
résine
nation et ce fatalisme auquel vous
voudriez nous condamnés nous ne croyons
pas contrairement au rassemblement
national nous ne croyons pas à
contrairement à la france est soumise
aux écologistes nous ne croyons pas du
tout qu'il faille renoncer à produire
qu'il faille renoncer à cultiver qu'il
faille renoncer à inventer
qu'il faille recommencé à offrir au
monde entier ce que nous pouvons lui
apporter de meilleures et nous savons
que dans l'agriculture aussi en exporte
autant le cognac que l'on exporte des
airbus dans la discrétion
et pourtant avec la même efficacité et
avec quelle performance et avec quelle
fierté aussi
et nous ne voulons pas renoncer à cette
fierté mes chers amis pour que cette
compétition économique à laquelle nous
croyons pour que cette liberté d'échangé
est un sens pour que ce doux commerce
dont parlait encore monter ce que puisse
rapprocher les hommes encore faut-il que
les règles soient les mêmes pour tous
nous croyons à les changes
mais comment se fait-il que nous n'ayons
jamais réussi à obtenir
comment se fait-il que nous n'ayons
jamais cherché même parfois à obtenir ce
qui devrait être la condition minimale
dans tout échange commercial une stricte
réciprocité
il faut que les règles soient les mêmes
pour tous
[Applaudissements]
le saviez vous c'est une statistique que
je ne cesse de répéter
d'ailleurs avec laurent ans sillonne la
france depuis des semaines maintenant il
doit plus en pouvoir de m'entendre
répéter les mêmes statistiques tout le
temps enfin il vaut mieux se répéter que
se contredire et quand on voit certains
qui sont entrés au gouvernement
aujourd'hui on se dit que cet univers ce
qu'on ne veut pas leur envier et puis
vous savez il paraît qu'il faut garder
mon côté profs alors la pédagogie c'est
la répétition donc je me répète donc le
saviez vous en europe et c'est très
important de le comprendre parce que ça
dit tout en europe 20% du pib est
constituée par des marchés publics et
bien en europe 95% de ses marchés
publics sont ouverts aux acteurs
internationaux
nous sommes les seuls au monde à croire
à cette ouverture inconditionné nous
sommes les seuls au monde
arrivée de la fin de l'histoire les
marchés publics américains ne sont
couverts qu'à 30%
les marchés publics russes 0% les
marchés publics chinois 0%
comment est il acceptable qu'une
entreprise chinoise puisse prendre un
marché public en france et faire du
profit en france alors que jamais la
meilleure entreprise française ne pourra
prendre un marché public en chine et
faire du profit en chine
voilà le scandale actuel est bien face
face à cette situation nous avons une
solution magnifique et cette solution
c'est l'europe
bien souvent on entend dire que notre
problème c'est l'europe et parfois hélas
c'est vrai mais notre solution aussi
c'est ce que l'europe a construit notre
solution c'est ce marché européen
ce marché commun un extraordinaire
atouts dans la mondialisation
aujourd'hui ce marché commun est une
proie et une cible facile
mais demain il peut être si nous le
voulons il suffit de le vouloir un
levier formidable pour pouvoir obtenir
enfin cette réciprocité dont nous avons
besoin car nous en avons besoin
nous croyons à la force de nos
entreprises mais la meilleure équipe du
monde si elle rentre sur un terrain de
football dont le terrain n'est pas plat
et où l'arbitré corrompu est sûr de
perdre le match
eh bien nous sommes capables de gagner
la coupe du monde nous sommes aussi
capables de gagner ces combats là encore
faut-il que le terrain soit plat et que
l' arbitre applique les mêmes règles à
tous et pour l'obtenir enfin il faut
utiliser la force de ce marché commun
quand vous êtes c'est ce que les
britanniques découvrent aujourd'hui à
leurs dépens après que d'autres se sont
félicités du bric site qui change
aujourd'hui discours quand vous êtes un
marché de quelques dizaines de millions
d'habitants une grande puissance dans le
monde peut facilement vous contourner et
si vous voulez échanger avec elle vous
savez que ce sera à ces conditions c'est
ce que vivent aujourd'hui les
britanniques y compris avec les
américains c'est leur amère déception il
avait cru devenir globale britten il
avait cru pouvoir nouer des accords
favorable avec le reste du monde
et bien aujourd'hui ils se rendent
compte que quand on est quelques
dizaines de millions d'habitants
on est contraint de se plier aux règles
qui nous sont imposées par de grandes
puissances mondiales
on peut aisément contourné un marché de
quelques dizaines de milles 2 millions
d'habitants
mais on ne peut pas contourner un marché
de 500 millions d'habitants on ne peut
pas contourner l'europe et si l'europe
se réveille quand l'europe se réveillera
alors elle sera invincible
elle pourra dire à ceux qui voudront
échanger avec elles venues échanger avec
nous venaient proposer ce que vous avez
fermé nous nous voulons pouvoir avoir le
même accès à vos marchés venaient si les
règles sont les mêmes pour tous nous
sommes prêts à jouer le jeu mais que
chacun joue le jeu et quand l'europe le
demandera alors personne ne pourra
contourner ce que l'europe exigera voilà
ce qu'il faut retenir
et voilà ce qu'il nous faudra obtenir
demain
et voilà cher guillaume en effet
pourquoi il est indispensable que nous
entrions nombreux au parlement européen
voilà pourquoi il est indispensable que
tu entres avec nos guillaume au
parlement européen pour une raison très
simple nous sommes membre d'une grande
famille politique européenne qui
s'appelle le ppe et bien c'est au sein
de cette grande famille politique que
cette réorientation dont l'europe a
tellement besoin pourra et pourra seul
s'opérer c'est au sein de cette grande
famille politique que la voix de la
france pourra être entendue c'est au
sein de cette famille politique qu'il
faudra peser de tout notre poids et
c'est pourquoi il faudra être nombreux
pour pouvoir faire entendre une voix
crédible une voix audible qu'il dira que
l'europe enfin doit se doter d'une
stratégie que l'europe
enfin doit rompre avec cette naïveté qui
nous a fait tant de mal encore faut-il
pour cela que la france soit crédible
pourquoi n'avons nous pas réussi à nous
faire entendre si longtemps de nos
partenaires européens
parce que nos partenaires européens
depuis bien longtemps
on fait les réformes qu'il fallait pour
se mettre au niveau de ce marché commun
que nous avons construit lorsque nous
sommes passés à un marché unique
lorsque nous avons fait la monnaie
unique l'allemagne faisait les grandes
réformes dont elle bénéficie aujourd'hui
et nous on faisait les 35 heures ça
pouvait pas marcher comme ça ça pouvait
pas durer longtemps et aujourd'hui nous
sommes citoyens de ce pays qui est
actuellement à la dernière place en
europe en matière de déficit public pour
la première fois depuis le début du
projet européen pour la première fois
emmanuel macron a mis notre pays
au 28e rang sur 28 en matière de
déficits publics
nous sommes depuis des années
déficitaires commercialement depuis des
années nous consommons plus que nous
produisons depuis des années nous
alimentons notre consommation
d'aujourd'hui par le poids des déficits
accumulés qui vont peser sur les épaules
des générations qui viendront et nous
sommes aujourd'hui inaudible dans le
débat européen
parce que lorsque nous avons demandé à
nos partenaires européens de protéger un
peu ce marché ils nous auront ils nous
ont répondu commencé par faire les
réformes qui vous permettront d'être
efficace commencer par renouer avec la
compétitivité commencer par vous
remettre en condition pour pouvoir de
nouveau exporter pourquoi aurions nous à
subir le poids de vos fragilité et nous
pouvons comprendre c'est vrai que
peut-être il est eu du mal à nous juger
très crédible quand vous êtes emmanuel
macron et que vous êtes le président qui
a réussi à mettre la france au dernier
rang des pays européens en matière de
déficit public derrière la grèce
derrière l'italie quand vous êtes
emmanuel macron et vous êtes le
président du pays qui prélèvent les
charges sociales et fiscales les plus
élevés au monde et qu'ensuite vous
écrivez une lettre européens en leur
disant chers amis européens
je vais vous expliquer à quoi devrait
ressembler l'europe
quand vous êtes le dernier de la classe
et que vous écrivez à vos petits
camarades en leur disant est ce que vous
voudriez pas commencer à me ressembler
un peu ça devient pénible de vous voir
toujours devant on comprend que les
autres vont regarder vous disent mais
qu'est ce que vous êtes pour nous donner
des leçons
alors oui c'est vrai oui nous sommes de
cette famille politique qui n'a pas
renoncé à dire que la france avait
besoin de faire des choix courageux pour
retrouver confiance en son avenir
oui nous avons besoin que l'europe
évolué oui nous avons besoin que nos
partenaires fassent leur part du chemin
mais oui nous avons aussi notre part du
chemin à faire
eh oui si nous voulons être crédibles
dans le débat européen il nous faudra
aussi avec l'exigence nécessaire prendre
les décisions qui s'imposent pour
pouvoir retrouver cet oxygène dont nous
avons tellement besoin
depuis le début de cette campagne je
l'entend partout en france tant de chefs
d'entreprise qui ont le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui créer un emploi est un
exploit infinie temps d'agriculteurs qui
ont le sentiment que pèse sur des normes
toujours plus compliqué des contrôles
toujours plus lourd au point qu'ils ont
le sentiment d'être quasiment traités
comme des délinquants tous les jours
tant d'artisans de commerçants qui sont
piégés par ces règles qui sont parfois
les derniers à se payer de leurs
salariés
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à s'en
sortir tant de gens qui travaillent et
qui ne s'en sortent pas qui travaillent
et qui n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux
bouts
parce que le travail ne paye pas parce
que nous avons le sentiment au fond de
cette asphyxie dans laquelle nous sommes
piégés et parce qu'à cette asphyxie
aussi bien monsieur hollande que son
ancien ministre monsieur macron ne cesse
de répondre par toujours plus de
dépenses publiques toujours plus de
complexité
le nombre de fonctionnaires on l'a
appris il hier a encore augmenté et je
ne dis pas cela parce qu'il faudrait
persécuter les fonctionnaires au
contraire j'en suis un et je sais
combien les enseignants de notre pays
souffre d'abord de la crise que notre
éducation nationale traverse et d'avoir
le sentiment d'être au front dans un
combat déprimant contre une sorte
d'impuissance collective dans laquelle
ils sont piégés à cause d'une
administration qui n'a pas su se
réorienter qui n'a pas su se réformer et
je sais aussi combien il est douloureux
pour les enseignants français pour les
fonctionnaires de france qui font vivre
les services publics de travailler à eux
aussi et parfois de travailler beaucoup
et d'être au front face à toutes les
difficultés sociales que traverse notre
pays est pourtant de ne pas s'en sortir
de ne pas pouvoir joindre les deux bouts
quand vous êtes enseignant à paris quand
vous êtes enseignant dans le centre
ville d'une grande métropole française
vous ne pouvez plus vous loger là où
vous enseigner oui nous avons besoin de
retrouver cet oxygène qui fera que le
travail paie y compris dans nos services
publics
et oui nous avons besoin de réformer
notre état parce que depuis de longues
années les français le voient très bien
le poids de la fiscalité n'a cessé
d'augmenter le poids des charges n'a
cessé de s'alourdir et les services
publics à la fin annoncée de se dégrader
de se complexifier de s'éloigner de
cette france rurale de cette france
périphérique de cette france des oubliés
oui on peut faire mieux avec moins
et oui on doit faire mieux avec moins et
nous sommes de ceux qui n'ont pas
relancé à l'oublier
et nous ne nous laisserons pas faire la
leçon par ses responsables politiques
issus de la droite qui mène aujourd'hui
une politique de gauche
il explique que nous sommes la france du
trocadéro que nous sommes la droite du
trocadéro eh bien nous n'avons pas
renoncé c'est vrai à cette droite qui
est fidèle à son message fidèle à ses
convictions fidèle à son projet fidèle à
ses électeurs
et s'ils veulent nous reprocher cette
fidélité là elle est pour nous notre
honneur et nous continuerons de dire à
temps et à contretemps à ce gouvernement
qui n'a rien fait pour sortir la france
des difficultés structurelles qu'il
connaît nous continuerons de dire que
l'essentiel du travail est devant et que
l'essentiel de ce travail ce sera notre
responsabilité
ensemble d'apporter à la france
l'alternative qui pourra le réaliser
enfin car oui ce défi est devant nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est la bataille de l'économie et de
l'emploi c'est la bataille pour
retrouver un équilibre dans notre
société mais retrouver un équilibre dans
notre société c'est aussi relevé tous
les autres camps défis qui nous
attendent
le défi écologique bien sûr et par où
passe t'il sinon par le fait de
rééquilibrer la mondialisation par où
passe le fait de retrouver un équilibre
par note pour notre environnement
sinon par le fait de pouvoir enfin
réapprendre à produire ce que nous
consommons aujourd'hui tu parlais de
sylviculture chéri dit aujourd'hui en
coupe du chêne dans les forêts
françaises
ce chêne on l'envoie en chine pour
devenir du parquet ou du mobilier et on
le ramène en france pour que vous
puissiez lâcheté sous forme de parquet
ou de mobilier est ce que ce monde est
sérieux comme tu le demandes est cher
guillaume est ce que ce nouveau monde
est sérieux
bien sûr que non il nous faut retrouver
un équilibre retrouvé un équilibre cela
suppose de réapprendre à produire ce que
nous consommons
quand nous achetons de l'agneau néo
zélandais vendus sur nos étalages de
supermarché à côté de l'agneau français
l'agneau français abattu trois semaines
avant d'être vendus la nuit néo
zélandais a battu des mois avant d'être
vendus cette année aux néo zélandais il
a traversé le monde pour arriver dans
votre assiette il a fait dix-huit mille
cinq cents kilomètres avant d'arriver
jusqu'à vous et il coûte moins cher que
l'agneau français pourquoi parce qu'il a
été cultivé élevé selon des standards
qui n'ont rien à voir avec les normes
que nous imposons à nos agriculteurs cet
agneau est arrivé sans payer les mêmes
charges sans subir les mêmes normes sans
respecter les mêmes règles et il est
vendu là après dix-huit mille cinq cents
kilomètres de trajet il a vécu me disais
un éleveur ovin récemment il a vécu plus
longtemps mort que vivant cet agneau néo
zélandais il a traversé la planète
et nous laissons ce faire ce monde de
flux perpétuel qui nous vite de notre
capacité de produire et qui déstabilise
le monde dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui
et ensuite on explique aux salariés
français qui a besoin de sa voiture pour
faire 5 km pour aller travailler que
c'est lui qui est responsable de la
catastrophe écologique que c'est lui qui
est responsable de la cne ce qui
m'attire alors mes chers amis c'est l'un
des grands défis de l'europe il faut
redonner un équilibre à la
mondialisation en réapprenant à produire
ce que nous consommons il suffira pas
comme le propose la république en marche
ah ça on reconnaît que la gauche n'est
pas morte il suffira pas puisque c'est
l'un de leurs grands projets dans le
programme de la république en marche
grand problème grandes solutions grandes
solutions grande dépense bien sûr la
gauche a des habits nouveau mais en fait
elle n'a pas changé
dépenser 1000 milliards d'euros chers
amis c'est le projet on sait pas trop
pourquoi faire le projet c'est la
dépense dépenser 1000 milliards d'euros
comme si ça pouvait être résorbé la
catastrophe écologique
chers amis ici il suffisait
d'additionner les dépenses publiques
pour remédier au problème climatique la
france serait un paradis climatique
en vérité la france mais la france n'est
pas un paradis climatique c'est juste un
enfer fiscal mais ça c'est un autre
sujet bref rééquilibrer la
mondialisation rééquilibrer la
mondialisation c'est aussi faire face
aux défis migratoires qui est devant
nous et non pas derrière nous laurent
vous en reparlera mieux que moi mais ce
défi migratoire fondamental il est la
condition d'un équilibre retrouvé
et c'est face à ce défi migratoire que
nous voulons que l'europe agisse car oui
nous sommes de ceux qui croient à
l'europe quand elle nous permet d'être
plus efficaces ensemble que si nous
étions seuls isolés face à l'ampleur de
ce défi qui peut croire sérieusement que
la grèce tout seul défendra c'est
disent-ils
mais qui peut croire que si un pays
européen est défaillant face à l'ampleur
de ce défi nous ne serons pas tous
affectés
quand l'italie ferme ses frontières
aujourd'hui les migrants passent par
l'espagne et c'est par les pyrénées
qu'ils arrivent aujourd'hui en france
alors oui c'est vrai nous avons besoin
d'une europe qui puisse de nouveau
assumer de maîtriser ses frontières face
aux flux migratoires pour pouvoir
accueillir vraiment ceux qui ont besoin
de notre solidarité nous voulons bien
accueillir et la ville fait partie de ce
que la civilisation européenne a produit
de plus beau nous voulons bien
accueillir mais nous ne voulons pas
subir et c'est tout autre chose
d'accueillir c'est tout autre chose
d'ouvrir la porte à celui qui vous a
demandé d'entrée et qui a besoin de
votre aide
que d'avoir sa porte enfoncée tous les
jours c'est tout autre chose d'ouvrir la
porte à quelqu'un qui vous demande
d'entrer pour l'accueillir entre vaut
mieux est de ne plus avoir de mur oui
nous voulons que l'europe puisse
maîtriser ses frontières et ce grand
défi là aussi est devant nous ce défi il
est nécessaire si nous voulons éviter de
continuer de produire du malheur à
grande échelle malheur pour nos sociétés
si profondément fracturé malheur pour
tous ces jeunes venus d'afrique qui se
laisse entendre le miroir aux alouettes
d'un eldorado qu'ils ne trouveront pas
s'il arrive en europe
nous ne pourrons redonner un avenir à
l'afrique nous ne pourrons redonner un
équilibre monde de demain que si nous
savons maîtriser de nouveaux nos
frontières et c'est un défi majeur aussi
pour que nous puissions retrouver cet
équilibre dont nos pays ont besoin car
le défi est devant nous le défi c'est
celui de l'intégration
le défi c'est celui de redevenir une
nation
le défi c'est celui de retrouver le sens
de ce qui nous relient les uns aux
autres une civilisation
voilà peut-être le dernier est le
premier thème le plus important d'entre
tous sans doute celui que nous avons
porté dans ce débat avec force depuis le
départ l'europe de redécouvrir ce
qu'elle est l'europe ça n'est pas
d'abord des traités l'europe ce n'est
pas d'abord des administrations l'europe
ce n'est pas d'abord un projet c'est
d'abord une civilisation c'est d'abord
un mérite à elle c'est d'abord une
histoire
l'europe c'est ce petit miracle discret
de la raison qui naît lorsque dans les
cités grecques
des hommes et des femmes décident qu'il
ne leur suffira plus d'expliquer le
monde avec des mythologies mais qu'ils
veulent désormais le logo ce qu'ils
veulent désormais la logique
l'explication rationnelle l'europe c'est
cette exigence de rationalité qui fait
que du logos nous passons au dialogue on
sait que le dialogue devient la
délibération collective par laquelle
nous écrivons ensemble notre avenir au
lieu de le subir c'est la démocratie
et lorsque nous parlons ensemble comme
ce soir
dans cette salle dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale ou du sénat comme
dans le plus simple conseil municipal
lorsque nous délibérons nous sommes les
enfants des grecs
l'europe c'est bien sûr le sens de
l'autorité de l'état c'est le sens de la
res publica c'est le sens de la chose de
tous c'est cette égalité devant la loi
qui fait que par le monde romain
diffusée dans tout l'espace lapin nous
découvrons qu'il n'y a pas de liberté
s'il n'y a pas d'autorité et si nous
sommes aujourd'hui les premiers à dire
que nous ne pouvons plus subir ce chaos
qui sèment le désordre dans nos centres
villes semaine après semaine
si nous sommes les premiers à dire que
nos désaccords doivent se dire dans le
cadre démocratique de la vie
républicaine c'est parce que nous sommes
les héritiers des romains et l'europe
enfin pourquoi ne pas le dire pourquoi
avoir tant tardé à la nommer
c'est cette magnifique histoire de la
tradition chrétienne qui apportait pour
le monde
le sens de la dignité humaine
oui voilà ce que l'europe doit dire
voilà ce que l'europe doit être voilà ce
que l'europe doit dire au monde de
demain
voilà ce que l'europe doit dire dans
cette tentation qui traversent notre
monde
ce que l'europe doit dire dans la
tentation de traiter l'humain comme une
marchandise parmi d'autres lorsqu'on
propose de louer ce par quoi une femme
peut donner la vie lorsqu'on propose de
manipuler l'humain pour faire de
l'eugénisme l'occasion de rentrer dans
nos corps comme sur le nouveau terrain
de compétition où l'exigence de
performance viendra faire ses ravages
l'humain n'est pas humain parce qu'il
est fort mais parce qu'il est vulnérable
voilà ce que l'europe a su découvrir
voilà ce qu'elle doit dire au monde
l'europe a inventé la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui sait
que cette dignité de l'homme est une
dignité inaliénable et que rien ne peut
la lui retirer et devant les tentations
techniciste devant la tentation
transhumanistes devant cet empire
américain qui a aujourd'hui la
possibilité de vendre des enfants sur
catalogue devant cet empire chinois qui
a annoncé récemment que de bébé venait
de naître génétiquement modifiées nous
devons faire entendre cette voix de
l'europe
cette voie d'une civilisation qui peut
encore dire au monde le sens de cette
juste mesure le sens de cette modération
le sens de cette passion de l'humain
rien n'est beau
rien mais bodies est un ancien maire de
bordeaux qui s'appelait michel de
montaigne rien et beau comme la forme de
l'humaine condition que chacun d'entre
nous porte en lui la forme de l'humaine
condition voilà ce que l'europe a
supporté montaigne était un grand
lecteur des grecs et un grand lecteur
des latins montaigne et celui sans doute
par qui s'est condensée cet héritage
commun montaigne est celui par qui nous
pouvons redécouvrir la jubilation de la
conversation de cet art de la conférence
qui fait aussi la saveur de notre vie
politique
montaigne est sans doute ce grand esprit
européen qui dans l'enquêté dans l'étude
et dans l'échangé dans les essais
montrent à quel point nous sommes nous
mêmes lorsque nous savons nous nourrir
de tout ce qui nous a précédé pour
pouvoir écrire les plus belles pages que
nous avons inventé
voilà ce qui fait leur profond et cette
europe là chers amis cette europe là
nous en aurons besoin pour relever les
plus grande bataille de demain et l'une
d'entre elles se nomment lutte contre le
terrorisme islamiste lutte contre
l'islam radical qui gangrène notre
société lutte contre le communautarisme
on le dit trop souvent l'europe c'est la
paix mais la paix est aujourd'hui
menacée elle est aujourd'hui fragile
menacée lorsque à la terrasse des cafés
des individus innocents sont tués
menacée lorsque certains doivent
pratiquer leur culte sous protection
militaire simplement parce qu'ils sont
de confession juive
menacé par tout ce qui fait les nouveaux
visages de la guerre qu'il traverse
notre pays face à ce défi majeur il faut
des réponses sécuritaires il faut des
réponses judiciaires mais il faut aussi
cette réponse fondamentale qui consiste
à redire ce qu'est la civilisation
européenne pour pouvoir de nouveau la
partager à tous les jeunes qui
grandissent en france et dont beaucoup
hélas grandissent sans se reconnaître
français sans ce savoir enfants de cette
europe à tous ces jeunes là il faut
donner quelque chose à aimer il faut
donner la france a aimé il faut donner
l'europe en héritage et voilà ce qui
fait le défi devant lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui
voilà pourquoi il faut savoir nommer
l'europe voilà pourquoi il faut savoir
la dir et les met de nouveau alors chers
amis devant tous ces grands défis devant
tous ces défis majeurs nous avons besoin
de vous vous comprenez l'ampleur
incroyable de ces enjeux auxquels nous
sommes confrontés malgré cette ampleur
incroyable on voudrait nous priver de ce
débat si nécessaire on voudrait nous
expliquer qu'au fond il serait encore
temps de vivre une nouvelle élection
contre contre marine le pen ou contre
emmanuel macron ils ne sont d'accord que
pour nous dire qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
d'être contre emmanuel macron rentrer
dans ce débat en disant je suis contre
marine le pen marine le pen rentrer dans
ce débat en disant je veux battre
emmanuel macron eh bien nous n'avons
qu'un seul but c'est de refonder
l'europe pour pouvoir rétablir la france
nous n'en pouvons plus de ces élections
contre nous n'en pouvons plus de ces
élections par défaut ne voulons plus de
ces élections où on n'a qu'à choisir
entre le pire et le pire
nous voulons et je vais vous le dire ce
soir ce qui me marque le plus la
première réunion de cette campagne celle
qui a eu lieu tout juste après mon
investiture à l'époque où les vents
contraires étaient encore bien fort
un journaliste était dans la salle de
cette petite réunion tout simple et il a
écrit un article dans lequel il disait
j'ai vu quelque chose d'étonnant
j'ai vu de la joie chers amis nous n'en
pouvons plus des élections triste et ce
soir ce qui me marque le plus c'est ce
dont vous avez tous parler à la tribune
avant moi c'est cette joie nous voulons
voter pour pour l'europe que nous
voulons pour la france que nous aimons
pour pouvoir refonder l'europe et
pouvoir rétablir la france et nous avons
besoin de vous pour cela nous avons
besoin de votre joie nous avons besoin
de votre voix et ensemble oui ensemble
nous allons faire la surprise
le 26 mai vive l'europe et vive la
france
[Applaudissements]